restant et puis c'est la confirmation de
notre reportage de jeudi dernier la
bataille du mcdo est bien engagée entre
la mairie de paris et les responsables
du port autonome qui projette
l'installation des fast food à proximité
de la tour eiffel la guéguerre du
hamburger aura-t-elle lieu au pied du
plus parisien des symboles voici à quoi
ressemblerait le projet mcdonald's le
25e fasse tout de la capitale installés
ici juste au bord de la seine mais dixit
la firme américaine intégré dans son
environnement un alibi refusé par la
mairie de paris
adversaire déclaré du projet la scène
c'est un patrimoine extraordinaire
d'ailleurs l'unesco a classé les berges
et tout le monde doit se battre pour les
protéger alors il ya un projet qui n'est
pas acceptable
il y aurait de la publicité bien entendu
cela ne peut pas être accepté et la
mairie de paris envisage donc de porter
l affaire devant les tribunaux passe à
l'extension tentaculaire de mcdonald's
elle se fait porte-parole de la culture
parisienne mois les organes non je ne
crois pas que ce soit bien ici interrogé
par an ce serait terrible dans la même
veine elle dans les environs d'accord
mais pas ici
c'est un monument historique je pense
que suffisant
le mal de dents paris pour éviter d'en
mettra ici chantait déjà cette touriste
l'allemand rajouter 5
un truc là je
on va essayer
j'aime bien et mcdo à laure manaudou sur
scène ou non le port autonome et la
ville de paris vont devoir s'entendre
quoi qu'il en soit paris ne sera jamais
manhattan même si l'on donne parfois
l'impression